severely malnourished born underweight
fighting for every breath
scenes repeated at almost every hospital
in afghanistan
unicef says children are the most
vulnerable
poverty hunger the spread of preventable
disease we've just got a nationwide
measles
outbreak under control because we've
been doing campaigns but now we have an
outbreak of acute watery diarrhea which
is weakening already weak bodies and
here we are in the hospital we're seeing
children with severe acute malnutrition
and complications with pneumonia
measles
you name it we're hearing stories
of of
mothers sending children to school in
the morning crying with hunger
many of these girls had breakfast
although it was just a piece of bread
and some green tea the morning session
is for girls 2200 are taught by 11
teachers at the only high school in
chamtala
for the 3 500 boys in the afternoon
session there are 18 teachers
graduated from this makeshift school
which has been in this state for the
past 12 years
she's now a volunteer teacher
although against the taliban ban on
older girls education she says even if
they came to school there is no tent to
accommodate them
my message to the world is that they
should unfreeze our reserves
if they're not going to help us they
should at least do that so that we build
our country with our own money and my
message to islamic emirate leaders is to
fix our schools build classrooms get as
teachers and help us to get an education
it's not just health and education
though
in addition to crippling sanctions on
afghanistan since the taliban takeover
the country is facing a number of
challenges which are contributing to
your humanitarian catastrophe the
drought that this country is facing is
the worst in the last three decades and
people are having to send their children
to sleep on an empty stomach
until a few years ago these fields were
green
but the changing weather patterns mean
no snow in the winter and no rain during
summer
barren land and contaminated water
brings disease
sending children to ill-equipped and
short-staffed hospitals
it's a cycle of misery in a country
under leadership learning to govern
abandoned by the rest of the world
afghanistan